-Guys, lately, everyone's
been talking about NFTs,
or non-fungible tokens,
which are popular,
a form of crypto art.
But NFTs can be
pretty confusing,
and there's a lot of
misinformation out there,
so I wanted to clear
some things up.
It is time for
"Fact Versus Fiction."
-Oh.
-♪ Fact ♪
♪ Fact or fiction ♪
-Let's get started.
First up, fact,
NFT artwork is
impossible to forge.
Fiction, but like the Mona Lisa,
all you really need
is a selfie with it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Here's another one. Fact,
Beeple is one of
the biggest NFT artists.
Fiction, the other Teletubbies
are very jealous.
-Oh.
-Is Beeple one?
-Beeple.
-Next up we have, fact,
NFTs are the latest
Ethereum-powered
cryptocurrency craze.
Fiction, if you repeat that
sentence to your grandfather,
his head will explode.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I don't know if that's fiction.
-Here's one, fact,
the total volume of all traded
NFTs is around $431 million.
-Ooh.
-Fiction, 95% of that
went to the top seller,
"Digital Dogs Playing Poker."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up we have, fact,
you can pay for NFTs
with a variety
of cryptocurrencies.
Fiction, you can also
pay for NFTs with Kohl's Cash.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's not true.
-I think that is true.
-And finally, fact,
digital artist Nurple
auctioned his masterpiece
"The Wizard's Tango"
for a whopping $3 million
worth of Trashcoin.
Also fact, we made up
that entire last sentence.
That's all the time we have
for "Fact Versus Fiction."